every game
has its superstars and valor and found
one pretty early
tens day that you talked about keep an
eye on shazam
there it is fury once again with ted
as he's good for two tens is probably
the best baron player
in the world and today we wanted to rank
some of his greatest plays
but we didn't do it alone we got the man
himself to chime in and give us the real
stories behind some of his sickest plays
but before we get into that i just want
to remind you guys to subscribe to the
channel if you haven't done so already
that way you'll never miss a video just
like this one
and with that let's get into the top 10
tens plays
kicking us off at number 10 is that time
tens came
face to face with his past finds the
greatest time ever to backstab through
window and blindside
dapper but tens and company holding on
but the response from cloud9 has been
swift as well but since
it's gonna go all the way for the ace
you have to be kidding me
at valerian challenges tens came face to
face with his first valor and team
cloud9 blue
a lot of people wanted to see the
matchup since it was like my old team
and stuff
but the team is a lot different than
what it was when i was on it so like
the way they played was a lot different
as a newly inducted member of sentinels
tens wasn't about to let any sort of
sentimental ties get in the way of
securing the dub
and he picked up an absolutely sickening
ace to open the match
finds the greatest time ever to backstab
through window and blindside dapper
but tens and company holding on but the
response from cloud9 has been swift as
well but since
it's gonna go all the way for the ace
you have to be kidding me
i just remember like at the ends i
screamed
or like i yelled like this game is easy
or something like that ice
cold coming in at number nine is a
filthy 3k on the attack it was their
defense that is the expected
weakness here comes an aggressive
paranoia intense it's gonna work on top
of it
3k to kick that round off a big start
here for c9 now they're starting to
build that confidence
this nasty hyper aggro play comes from
ten's time on
c9 up against his future teammates in
sentinels at flashpoint
relic set tens up from merciless updraft
3k by giving him a perfect omen flash
through the wall
on the attack it was their defense that
is the expected weakness
here comes an aggressive paranoia
intense is going to work
on top of it 3k to kick that round off
because i i used to like do like a lot
of aggressive stuff in scrims to see if
it works and that was like one of the
things that actually worked
so we did it in the match and it worked
really well
taking number eight is a quick 4k clutch
that shows tens is a valorance best even
when he isn't playing pro matches
so i'd say for this play this was kind
of like one of those days you just feel
crispy
like you can you can see that i'm really
confident
in my aim where i'm like bursting
rather than spraying and
when i'm on point i feel like uh
with a vandal it can be pretty deadly i
think we can all agree
deadly describes this clutch perfectly
and number seven is a spectacular deagle
4k
at least if sick can do anything about
it the confidence on austin has he's
gonna spray away but he gets dropped by
tens
this is huge three big kills from tens
and the last one is 4k now
notably this whole play happened off
camera because the observers were
well they were busy i guess the point is
no one has ever seen this play from 10's
perspective
other than the man himself i i had to
hit these shots because i was missing
all my op shots
prior in all the other rounds we would
have closed out the map
a lot faster if i was just hitting some
op shots
and so i ended up popping off with the
sheriff
our number six pick is the perfect
example of a nasty flick
only tens himself could ever hope to hit
let's play that again in slow mo tens
pulled off
an insane flick onto the sky outside of
b
and then hunted down the omen catching
him in mid
air i've even in counter-strike i did
this thing where
um i'll like 360 and then flick one tap
and then switch my gun as i'm like
um what's it called after like i once up
make it look cool sometimes it's all
about the style points
at the halfway point on our list is 10
single-handedly
shredding luminosity at masters he's got
the frenzy
and he's got a kill man all up and moves
his face and he's getting a jumping one
as well on the thief
i said this the first time i called tens
this is his world
and we're just living in it so fun fact
about this one
10's actually loaded onto the server
with the wrong mouse sensitivity
yeah i'm an idiot um one of my mice i
was using for league of legends so i was
trying out 600 dpi because i think faker
was playing on it
um and i wanted to try it out so when i
was switching between my mice
um on the second map i think it was
i was on the or it was on it was on a
scent i remember
it was on the wrong sense and i didn't
really realize because i switched my
scent so much that like
everything felt normal to me in a way i
did feel like extra fast like when i
switched the mouse i was like yeah this
mouse is lighter than i remember
but it's actually this double my dpi not
only was he playing with settings for an
entirely different game
he was also making his return to pro
play after three months of content
creation
and yet he still managed to pull this
off he's got the frenzy
and he's got a kill man all up and moves
his face and he's getting a jumping one
as well on the thief
i said this the first time i called tens
this is his world
and we're just living in it he's got
four he's going hunting for the ace
let him off the leash he's digging it
this map entirely
made me really confident for the rest of
the event
like i i left i left the pro scene and
then
i didn't play for um
like three three months i think it was
or something like that and then
i come back and i realized that not much
has changed
coming in at number four is another
example of tens doing something so
absolutely insane he literally surprised
himself
uh yeah
what what this one simply defies
explanation double updraft over the wall
to one tap the sage
on site it was so crazy tens didn't even
believe it
did you see that what did you just do
i was so shocked when this hit because
i'm kind of realizing it now that the
sheriff is definitely more
way more accurate than the deagle but
it's kind of like in cs if you just like
jumping jiggle someone from across the
map it's like
that shouldn't happen um
i was just i was blessed by rng right
there
our number three pick is proof that good
things come
to those who wait the trigger disappears
[Music]
beautiful work from tens during c9's
match against dignitas at the pop flash
valorum invitational tens waited for the
perfect moment to strike
and then his trigger discipline paid off
they can just play very passively they
have a lot of sound cues to know that oh
this could be so patient the trigger
oh my god well beautiful work from tens
he got set up and that was a slam dunk
because i saw the first guy walk up
i probably should have killed the second
guy right away but i got a little bit
greedy and
went for a third and it worked out
sometimes patience
really is a virtue
our runner-up play is a disgusting
martial
4k that kept sentinels winning in
iceland by fanatic 10's able to find the
headshot onto durka
the pressure is coming through though
still a problem that spike
keeps getting restarted on the defuse
doma has to stick it for tens
nails doma with that marshall at
distance at masters
sentinels were having a tough time on
haven seaside
that is until 10 stepped up with the
marshall and took fnatic apart
he knows at that point oh my god i can't
believe what we're seeing here from
tens but after you get that board
position on sick
you can either try to bait rotations
into him oh my god it's just disgusting
isn't it
from my pov entirely it even looked that
sick it was just
i was peeking and they were kind of
crouching into my crosshair
like that's how it felt for me ten seems
to always grace us with a martial
highlight reel in this particular spot
and while he's being pretty modest about
it it's still
totally blew our minds
there's really only one play that could
take the number one spot on our list
the four bullet of ace but now
immortals after that last one are you
choking me
his town's really just pulled they know
they're collateral
immortals
what what can they even do they make
their way on site
no tags that's right
this place starts off with a collat and
then just keep getting
better from there it was so crazy the
casters
didn't even know what to say it'd be
what it be my friend but now
immortals after that last one are you
choking me
has 10's really does pull they know
they're collateral
not again two in a row
uh sure man i mean at this point
he's death immortals immortals
what what can they even do they make
their way on site
no and everything i used i was so
confident with the op when uh prior to
like the nerve
and like uh the fire rate was faster
like i actually felt so
confident just going for aggressive peak
after aggressive peak i just like
peaking constantly
um i'm kind of glad that they nerfed the
gun because it was a little bit op
i would say but um yeah i remember this
clip it was it was pretty nice
pretty nice come on this clip is proof
that tens
isn't even human well there you have it
the top 10
best plays from tens as chronicled by
the man himself
how cool was that did we miss out any
ones that really should have been on the
list
let us know also let us know what you
want to see next on the channel
thanks for watching guys and i'll see
you all in the next one
your kind a i know i'm sorry i'm sorry
that's not tyson's fault